[Music]
all right we ready to go I'm ready
Miguel I've curiosity here with all
these let's get into it do you want to
know well I want to know if there's
meaning behind them where they're just
like you know it's all relatively
intentional I mean a lot of the one of
the things when you run a podcast you
get all the books in the mail ahead of
time and I interview a lot of authors so
I get a lot of cool books so a lot of
these are from guests or they're just
things that I'm interested in right yeah
Scott you know Scott right yeah and
stuff at your water I have not had David
Lynch on but I would like to and have
you ready go is the enemy no I Ryan
holiday no I was wondering whether you
might have met him along the way because
Ryan was the head of marketing for
American Apparel overreact in the day
and I actually he texted me this morning
about something else and I said hey
Miguel's coming over to do the podcast
you guys must have met at some point he
was very young at the time and he said
I've been racking my brain trying to
remember whether we met we must have at
some point but he just didn't remember
yeah yeah I mean I would say the same
way right I may have but you know it was
wild times well let's get into the wild
times man it's been quite a journey I
think when I think about we work and and
everything that you've accomplished and
and you know your mission it seems like
every once in a while maybe just a
couple times in a generation there's a
really great idea that happens to
coincide with a shift in culture and
then like some fairy dusting of timing
and a lot of hard work and persistence
of course that kind of creates the
foundation for something so you know
seismically impacting as what you've
created with we work you know what I
mean like like yeah I cuz I think about
like the way people work today is not
the way people work in general like when
I was a kid right and so this idea that
you had it wasn't you weren't the first
person to come up with the idea of
co-working that existed but you did it
at scale and in a way that really
leveraged this change in our relation
ship to the workplace and work in
general with the kind of emergence of
this freelance culture and how the
Internet has allowed people to to you
know do what they do remotely even when
they work for large companies yeah and
it's the the reason why I responded to
that I guess feeling a little bit
overwhelmed is that it still feels like
we're so in it like we're in that moment
where the change is still happening and
evolving and it feels I guess to me
still rough in that way I don't know how
to describe that but it feels still like
we're in the journey so much that when
it when you think of it I was like that
as a shift that almost seems like a
conclusion or a change that's
perceptible I think we're still right in
the heart of that change like we're
still so close to what's going on that
that to hear it described that way I
mean obviously it feels great and I
appreciate it but I also feel like we
have so much more to do yeah but just
for perspective I mean this thing only
started in 2008 which might seem like a
lifetime ago to you but really just
wasn't that long ago yeah and I think
whereas in the early days it was like
cool idea now it's like wow you know you
walk into you go riving in Jakarta
seeing the wework sign on a big tower
you know walking in and feeling this
incredible warmth and like vibe of
people feeling happy and connected to
each other
that's when it's like surreal clicks
into like real very quickly and it feels
really good what I hear in that is is
the idea of community which seems to be
kind of a lifeblood for you I mean that
that theme permeates throughout your
life and really you know in my
imagination at least is the life force
that kind of ignites you know all of
this for you yes you're scaling you're
in all these cities you
this is a huge organization that you're
now you know at the top of but at its
core this is about trying to connect
people for sure and I it's interesting
because that is still my deepest
interest so what's interesting when it
comes to the scale is that you can look
at the business overall and there's
something interesting and impressive and
you value it on a large scale it's like
wow that's achieving something but to me
in the day to day what I really care
about is connecting with people and so
for example I mean we came to LA this
week
and what I did this morning was what we
call lead leader circle which was I
think about fifteen of us sitting in a
circle for two hours telling stories
about our lives about where we come from
about how we connect our past to who we
are now and that's the stuff that I love
I mean there was tears there were you
know laughs there were you know there
was inspiration and that's the stuff
that like I'm like this is why I do it
you know it's those are the things that
I feel really fulfilled by and like um
and it's and then not I don't think I
hope that never goes away
I mean that's like but yeah that's the
part that just feels so good and so
that's the part that I hunger to
actually do that really well and that we
talk about all the time like how do we
not waste our time when we bring people
together because if you have an
opportunity to connect
don't waste it yeah you know how can you
be intentional and structure these
interactions in a way that will you know
allow people to you know deepen their
their relationship to each other yeah
and in that way one thing that's really
interesting one of the struggles that we
have and we've designed we work for that
connection when we're outside of the we
work setting and we like for example you
know the team like booked a restaurant
for a dinner tomorrow night
and now we know that most restaurants
suck for connecting for really
connecting I mean maybe if you're two
people and you can really sit
face-to-face but if you're six and
you're on the end of the table or you
know you're eight you're definitely not
connected
as a group right it's just nice you're
an introvert and you're at the end of
the table you sit there you know
twiddling your thumbs exactly and full
of anxiety and it could be three hours
of that right and that's like torture I
think if you're that person what is the
we eat plan for addressing that well I
think the first thing is for us to
actually be like you said purposeful
about those decisions so we're actually
looking for a new reservation because of
course when I come to town people always
take me yellow the cool restaurant I
don't care about the cool restaurant at
all I want to go to the place that
actually is quiet that's conducive to
conversation where we can actually feel
like we're sharing our time together in
a way that's valuable and so that's
that's the design process that we're
working on so we're actually in the
process today of looking for a different
place to hold that so that we because we
know we failed a lot like we've gone and
I've actually left those some of the the
dinners being like angry that we wasted
those three hours because I didn't feel
connected and so I aspire every time to
make that time valuable I was at a
friend's birthday party a couple weeks
ago it was a small dinner party I'm 20
people all at one long table and in an
effort to address that very issue that
problem the host the the guy whose
birthday it was said here's what we're
gonna do everyone's gonna we're gonna
we're gonna nominate one person to be
kind of the moderator and we're all
gonna go around we're gonna introduce
ourselves and we're gonna talk about
like what's top of mind right now for
each of us or what we're working on or
like something that you know we feel
strongly about and then we'll kind of
collate all of these ideas and figure
out what's most interesting to talk
about as a group and that way it
integrated everybody into the
conversation so there was no
marginalized person at the end of the
table and then it just went on its own
way but it was actually kind of amazing
and I did leave that experience feeling
like I had had a meaningful exchange
with every single person at that dinner
so it is like that how can you bring an
intentionality to this rather than just
sit down like hey how was your day what
are you doing great and how often do you
have that experience where you know you
happen to speak to the person who was
sitting next to you but then no one else
you know or maybe one or two other
people are
like you're feeling bad because you're
ignoring that person because you're
talking about exactly yeah and I think
that there's that intentionality is
important on multiple levels but I do
think that it can be awkward and so I
think for me that's been a something
that you know I try not to take for
granted that I'm in a position where I
can say things and do things because of
my whatever position or success or
whatever it might be where people yeah
like to some extent like like I can
actually be a convener because of that
and I don't think and so I don't take
that for granted like I I believe that
like we've tried stuff where like send
an email in advance giving people some
instructions about how they should show
up to something I think some people
would be like [ __ ] you like what are you
telling me how I'm supposed to act or at
a party or whatever it's weird but I
think people have at least in my
evolving Network people are buying into
that and I think that's what like we
want to prove that through some of that
design we can make those experiences
valuable and then people will hunger for
them and will continue to be able to
evolve that and I don't want to I mean
I'm not taking credit I should you know
Priya Parker's book the art of gathering
was one of the things that really
switched that on for me because I had it
in mind but I hadn't like really got
into like tactics of that stuff yet and
then in reading her book I was like so
many points where I was like you know
Chuck notes and I'm like I'm doing that
tomorrow you know I'm executing on that
stuff and so um so I think that ladder
is up to something much bigger hopefully
eventually but right now I think that's
like we do have the macro of like we're
creating these spaces where we believe
they are conducive to connection and
openness and we promote that idea in a
big way and now I think we're really
getting into not just me but other
members of our team getting into that
like what are the practices that are
truly connective and how can we then
start to you know systematize those
things make them scalable allow other
people to be able to facilitate once we
learn the tools yeah
and so but then that's really exciting
too
because when you think about our scale
it's like one thing to be like wow it's
cool we're have so many locations then
if you really believe that those
locations are amazing at connecting
people they're the best places in the
world for that to happen then it goes to
a whole nother place right well let's go
back to the beginning because the seeds
of this communitarian sensibility go
back to day one for you right
communitary is that a work I don't know
I like it though you just need
communitarian communitarian community
oriented yeah this runs in your blood I
mean you had a very unorthodox childhood
growing up on this commune run by strong
women so tell me about this yeah it's
weird cuz commune is like the most
simple word to describe the idea of
communal living but I think there's also
some people associate commune with like
cult and other stuff ideological stuff
that perhaps gets weird
it was very purposeful meaning the women
in my family made the choice to live
collectively share responsibility for
different parts of their lives that you
know we're both like replacing some of
the things that normally happen in
biological family but then also going to
another level in terms of like how do
they get by you know so when they wanted
to like live off the land at the time or
be more disconnected from society it's
like well some people had to have jobs
you know to like sometimes need money
for stuff but it was very purposeful and
they had ideals about how we as kids
would be raised they were very
comfortable
all of them with having kids without the
fathers being in the picture and so
there were five women who and there were
others peripheral but there were five
core women these are like friends of
your mom yeah how does this even come
together well it's weird I've actually
over the years I keep asking that you
know just recently I've been like
recording my mom telling the story so I
I hope I'm telling them right and I
don't want to steal their stories I
think they they should be the ones who
tell him but my mom in like literally
her like freshman roommate you know at
Boulder became friends and then they you
know
the New Mexico Colorado scene connected
with other women and I became this crew
who were living together and in a very
again like an idealistic notion like
they were actually I mean the way they
described it they were like the hippies
were fighting back they were like we're
done we're out you know they were like
that you know they were like extreme in
the sense that they were like we've lost
connection to what's going on in the
world right now we have to find
something different and so they really
were trying to live completely outside
of reliance on on right you know and a
lot of the words that we have now like
freegans and communitarians you know
yeah they were they were they were that
and they you know so there's amazing
stories of like them literally getting
their food from the dumpster in the back
of a grocery store right you know
idealistic way not because they were I
mean they were poor but they weren't
poor meaning like the like that like
they were doing it for the sleet lee
opted out of anything class oriented
exactly and then so and there's a bunch
of influencing factors that affected
their migration but when they got to
from New Mexico to Eugene where I grew
up they did have to reenter society more
formally because of us kids were all in
close in age so you know similar ban of
of ages but we all they wanted us to go
to school and so you know we went to
public school and they had jobs for a
period of time you know my mom was like
a latchkey teacher right after school I
don't know what she got paid you know we
had food stamps you know was it
stigmatizing for you like to go to
public school and have everybody else
doing the traditional thing yeah I mean
I did grow up in Eugene I would say was
a it was a there was a hippie vibe there
that was accepted you know like there
were kids at school who had weird names
I mean not Miguel is not a weird name if
you're Hispanic but Miguel's a weird
name for like a white kid and there were
other kids named you know wind and write
you know Morningstar an evening star and
that summer those kind of acts so it
wasn't so weird but um but definitely
there were times like I didn't grow up
with my father and you know there were
times where I aspired to be normal so I
would say someone say oh what is your
mom doing mm-hmm I don't know for sure
exactly like how you would define that
she's like me now I'd say oh she's a
community activist she's on you know
public access TV you know she's doing
all kinds of stuff that's cool now when
I look back at it but as a kid trying to
define their parents job it was very
weird and then my father was in the
picture so I would say oh you know my
father is police officer on he's
undercover you know you know I made up
stories to try to put him in a context
that made me feel more normal but at the
same time I will say there was weirdness
but we were also you know really like
connected you know like we're a part of
something like every weekend I was on a
couch at someone's house who I didn't
know potluck music dancing you know
people hanging out felt creative felt
just good and and I knew so I knew I was
a part of something bigger whether I
understood it or not you know and I was
totally safe like I would like you know
just fall asleep on the couch that
probably aged five or six at someone's
house I don't even know where I am but I
just felt totally comfortable there
because I just knew I was up we were we
were community we were like a connected
group of people well the word commune is
such a loaded term they you know has a
lot of baggage associated with it but
essentially what was happening as far as
I can tell is really the way that humans
evolved to live in tight-knit groups of
people not in you know insulated family
units but as no naughty and not as large
as villages but in you know groups
probably the size of what you were
raised in and in many respects that
feels right and I
I know as a parent of four kids and we
live way out in the country like not
having you know there is a sense of not
feeling as connected as I have been you
know to people in the past and there's a
yearning for that like wouldn't it be
great like that's why we I was telling
you before the podcast like we've gone
through phases where there's like been
like nine or ten people living here like
we've kind of run our own little you
know loose knit version of that and it's
nice and when you come here like you can
imagine if you had like five more of
these little retainers yeah eventually
yeah you know what I mean and and
there's a comfort to that that feels
very human and and the way that it
should be you know and I feel like on
McCulloh it's not rigged to promote that
but would we not be better off if there
was more of that going on yeah and and
and so really you know my question is
like how do you think about I mean
you've kind of already answered it a
little bit but like that experience of
growing up in a communitarian
you know environment like how does that
inform how you think about the
communities that you're trying to create
and cultivate and and foster and grow in
these spaces that you know you now
create I mean there's to me it's like
you know you can always see things 2020
in retrospect but it's almost like it
was perfectly designed to put you in
this position to be able to recreate the
best parts of what that childhood
experience taught you in the workplace
and now in the living space yeah and
it's like you said reflection makes
things make sense you know and I think
that at the time when I was a kid I
definitely had some rebellion to the
communal hippie vibe you know like I
wanted to eat McDonald's and not yeah
you know co-op tempeh you know and so I
had this like I did in some way
rebelling the sense of business and I
also grew up in Eugene where Nike
started and I think that's a really
important part of my history in terms of
understanding like yeah I was in this
communal environment but I also
saw this energy that came from something
very commercial in sport and design
focused and so later on that all adds up
to yeah you know a business that is
based in community but also is about
brand it's about you know some level of
coolness and understanding how you need
that ability to message something and
brand something correctly in order to
like get people to you know to be a
light and it has an and the aspirational
ethos of it yeah exactly and I think
that's a really important part to say
like there are things that are truly
good in the world that are community
focused part of the reason that we've
been able to scale and bring it to like
a mass of people has been because we've
also been really good at the business
side right like and that's what I think
you don't think of as like oh the hippie
dippie people like all about you know
saunas and like you know yoga yeah that
you you then it's like they don't make
it you know and there are other brands I
have similar influences but it's like
that's kind of things like how do you
get that to be more of a mainstream
thing and I think that is where you said
it was also a good timing because a lot
of that stuff has emerged more you know
and it's not just us I think there are a
lot of other more mainstream places
where this kind of stuff is part of the
culture I mean your existence and
podcasts obviously as an example it's
like you know people are more interested
in trying to get in touch with this
stuff mm-hmm
yeah you those sensibilities are
important but if you're allergic to
spreadsheets it's not gonna work right
like so how do you meld and merge the
best of those worlds to like alchemist
all of that yeah that's part of I mean
for me personally like that was the part
that I felt the community I took in a
way for granite like I knew I didn't
like the office environment like I was
sure that was wrong you know like I knew
that that wasn't a good place for human
beings on a day-to-day basis that wasn't
even a question but it but the response
wasn't that like I wasn't
you know I was actually against some of
using the word community in the early
days because I didn't want to claim
something that we didn't actually have
and I and to me a community is a really
complex thing you know of a lot of
different factors where does it you know
how does it really feel like a community
it's not like you just say you you you
community yeah yeah it's not something
that you can control yeah you can create
you can create an environment that's
conducive to it but then there's a
letting go right for sure and that was
so that was part of the thing and Adam
and I um you know had some like early
day arguments about that because he
would be like wow you know why can't we
call it a community or why can't we use
some of the imagery related to community
in like the early marketing materials
and stuff and I was like you know we
really have to do it before we talk
about it you know and we have to prove
that it's possible before we start you
know because people would see that as
fake I think if you if you try to um so
we didn't talk a lot in the beginning I
mean we talked to like the landlords and
the people we needed from a business
perspective but we didn't like we
weren't that we weren't telling that
story that much in the early days all
right so you're in this interesting
living environment you're six foot eight
right yeah you like how tall were you
when you were like 14 15 is always big
I'm like scaled always been bigger
uh-huh like so you know all the school
photos like my head was above everyone
else
Nikes down the road you're interested in
sports so what you start playing
basketball at school like how does you
know how do you start coming in athletes
interesting environment my son who now
is nine and is a great basketball player
it's really interesting to compare
because his skill level you know I just
played for fun when I was a kid and I
played every sport baseball football
basketball not every sport that's a
narrow range of sports but they're the
like you know seasonal natural guns that
you can be a part of his kid and
basketball I didn't really become
serious about until the summer before
eighth grade and to be honest like I was
a really overweight kid I eat a lot of
McDonald's literally like I would say
the joke but McDonald's and talk about
where my
sources of your mom's like working hard
to ban glyphosate you're sneaking off to
the golden RG yeah but that's you know
that was a great thing about my mom is
that Shh
as much as she was like so on top of all
the right stuff to do
she also wasn't forcing on me she liked
me to mop yeah but she wasn't gonna be
like you have to eat this disgusting
stuff which to me at the time was gross
like I was really like tofu is the worst
you know but she let me do it you know
she took me through the drive-thru
because that's what I wanted and you
know who knows that all philosophical
stuff we could debate a lot and now that
I'm a parent like what should I do I'm
not sure I do
obviously organic is best but you know
that for sure but anyway sports
definitely became like a part of my
identity when I was in like high school
and that you know being a basketball
player like meant something and and I do
think that the learnings of like you
know team and and really being willing
to like both stand up and stand out you
know and be like recognized but then
also be like totally part of part of a
you yeah
and I think I learned those lessons in a
way that um that I think sports are one
of the few places where you can write
but I wasn't like a superstar player or
anything I was just like a good player
but you know playing at University
Oregon right yeah yeah I did which I
mean now looking back on it like again
that's like an accomplishment which
sounds cool and I'm really proud of my
time there and you know I really enjoyed
it but I also was a super good student
in architecture school and I love that
you know just as much so it was very
balanced didn't you go did you go to
Colorado College first yeah so I went to
Colorado College for two years and
there's a great moment that I had which
I always got a shout out this guy Carl
Reed who was a sculpture professor at
Colorado College and um you know I took
his class Colorado College I don't know
if you know the format there but I don't
promote it it's like one time for a
block for a month and so you know
whatever you're taking like total focus
like zeroed in on one subject matter so
one of my favorite classes there was
African American folklore where you
literally read like a book a day for a
month which was intense but amazing but
anyway so I go into sculpture class and
I'm making like whatever came to me and
this professor said and I and I don't
know what I'm doing at all like I'm like
I like art it's way better than
economics or math or any other stuff and
it's also an escape like art class for a
month you know pretty awesome no you
know yeah so that's all you have to do
yeah that's it yeah it's like go to
studio and that's it make stuff you know
all the time and it was it was great and
he says to me goes you know hey your
sculpture is really architectural and
I'm like what do you mean is like yeah
well you know if you look at it it looks
like you're sort of solving spatial
problems and you know structural
problems and I was like well that's cos
you should think about that for graduate
school and by chance and he didn't know
where I was from other things that I you
know University of Oregon is a great
program you should think about it so
that planted a seed where I was like oh
whoa like I don't know what I'm doing
with my life I don't have like a major I
don't know what my future holds I was
really actually unhappy at Colorado
College not for reasons that apply to
the school but more with the basketball
team and stuff and so that just clicked
I was like yeah oh wow and then I
immediately from that moment forward I
like went to the library and like got an
architecture book you know I got a
Corbusier book I got a Frank Gehry book
yeah and Corbusier and Geary are like so
different in terms of their approach to
architecture but amazing and the impact
that they had on the profession and on
and so by luck I mean literally I got
those books by luck and so I just
completely was all in on that and I
spent the whole summer that following
summer just literally like check out
book study it memorize everything in the
book and then return and get another one
on your own
completely
and they just and then you transfer yeah
and so then I transferred an but I had
to apply still to the architecture
school so I had actually like a year out
of not out of school but mostly out of
school and that that was like tough
thing for like for a high achieving
person and you know someone who had um
now that I was like in love with school
but I definitely was like good grades
and all that so to have like a year out
where I was kind of idle was tough but I
think that I got really to know myself a
lot better during that time because um
because I had to be I wasn't in the
format anymore you know like when you're
in school it's like you just show up in
the format and it's like yeah papers do
or the projects do if you show up in
that construct and you know you're
successful it's easy but then once
you're freed of that it's like whoa yeah
like you have to make your own decisions
about what's creating your own
curriculum to fill that time in the
in-between yeah yeah and I was working
at a restaurant you know busboy right
and just like you know trying to fill
myself up to prepare because I wanted to
be the best like to be honest like I was
like I want to be the best they're gonna
be the best architecture student and who
were who were your guys I mean you
started with Corbusier in gear yeah well
it's interesting because Geary has
always remained an inspiration to me
primarily because of his early days
explorations where he was really going
against you know a lot of things in
terms of the diagram and he would say
that he's still like uses a diagram and
stuff but alas stuff is just wild you
know yeah and and and a lot of the
professors that it were University of
Oregon at the time didn't appreciate him
like didn't like him they thought he was
just arbitrary making all these weird
shapes for no reason and so I like being
kind of counterculture in that way so
for that reason I appreciate him and I
still do the other is that when he did
Bilbao the Guggenheim Museum there I
think he took architecture to a whole
new place where the reason for that and
the reason why Bilbao invested in that
project was because they wanted to
define themselves as a culture they were
like this industrial place you know they
weren't known as like having
good you know like whatever the could
they weren't a culture Center you know
and so they said with architecture we
can reform you know and treat this
almost like culture heritage I think and
define themselves as a region you know
in that whole region which has obviously
great food but but and that and that to
me was like whoa this actually became a
branding exercise and this again sounds
weird when you transfer it in the
commercial but it really is it's like
that building in Bilbao was a commercial
draw it was a tourist attraction it was
a redefinition of a place it was alike
we completely yeah you can't think about
Bill you can't think about Bilbao
without thinking about that building
they're inextricably lived and that that
structure really defines you know how we
you know think about urban landscapes
and experiences them I mean that is it
is that is the brand of that city yeah
so to me I was like whoa that's a whole
different thing than I had ever
experienced before and I have
appreciation for other you know I mean
there's cool things about Frank Lloyd
Wright there's cool things about Louie
Caan there's really cool things about
modern you know some of the contemporary
architects Hertzog and Dame are on you
know there's people doing amazing stuff
but I think a lot of a lot of the stuff
in our world now stems from Bilbao like
the whole starchitect notion the whole
like meaning of buildings I think
changed from that and and so for me the
connection to that was I want to do
something that goes beyond just the
influence just the goodness of good
design but actually something that moves
culture forward in some bigger way yeah
well I'm a huge fan and somebody who
appreciates great architecture and
somebody who's experienced the impact of
great architecture up close and personal
like we live in an architectural home
very blessed you know
be in this space we were talking about
it a little bit before the podcast and I
can't imagine what my life would have
been like living somewhere else because
this structure has been
like this crucible for everything
creative that my wife and I have been
able to accomplish and it's the
environment in which we raised our kids
and the memories and just the daily
experience of being in a structure
that's oriented around like how we come
together as a family unit and how we
experience nature and how we engage with
our creative selves like it's a very
underestimated thing in our culture we
just think how you build a building or
you build a house but when there's
mindfulness and intention that goes into
how a structure is created in the sense
that it's oriented around promoting
those you know a certain set of values
it shapes how you live every aspect of
how you live yeah well I'm it I get I
mean I'm just so excited to hear you say
that because what I get extremely
frustrated by seeing things that are
done for reasons other than that mm-hmm
you know and there are buildings built
for show houses or first you go oh yeah
yeah and I mean there's so many there's
just in any number of stupid expressions
of other things other than having like
good motivations for design and there's
you know and and there's dumb stuff
that's just like oh there's a house with
a great view of nature and they didn't
even put a window in the right place you
know so there's some of that stuff
they're just like how like you have this
amazing Vista like the ocean and you
know or you know there's people who keep
their curtains closed all the time to
that view and I'm like how but um but
then there's like the next level then
there's like actually designing for
intent actually designing with purpose
and trying to understand you know the
flow of life and there's this building
that actually I've always loved which
you have something similar here I would
curious how it affects you but um
there's a Tadao Ando building a very
small house in in Tokyo where he
designed the living spaces in the front
and the bedrooms in the back and there's
a there's a courtyard in a bridge
between the two and his idea was you
know waking up or going
to bed experience nature in between and
whether it's cold whether it's rainy
whether it's hot you're just gonna know
because every day you have to you know
make that transition and it's a very
simple idea but one that seems so
beautiful and elegant to be like you
can't avoid it like you've got a yeah
you know connect to it
and and and I think that's that
intention I think is something that's
missing in who knows what 90% of stuff
that's built yeah yeah for our to go to
our master bedroom we you have to go
outside oh you do I want our cats
yeah back inside and outside and how
does that is it like people are like why
would you design a house that like you
that must be a mistake I'm like no that
was very intentional you know and I love
it I think it's a fantastic and look we
don't live in Minnesota so is there a
time where you're like it's pouring rain
or something you're annoyed or is it
like another that would be bad well I
mean this is you know this house is at
its best in the summer for sure you know
when it's raining a lot it's it can be a
little bit of an annoyance but it's not
that big of a deal you know and yeah we
purposely set off the containers like
out a distance from the house you know
make you engage with the outside a
little bit and create a little
separation and we have the communal you
know the communal aspect of the house is
separated from the private quarters and
you have to go outside again to go in
between both of those and the whole idea
is to bring nature into the experience
and it's a modern house but it's not
austere and the in the the sense of what
people think of modernism and a
traditional sense because it has the
rustic elements of the nature and those
doors slide open and it brings that
natural experience into the into you
know your experience of life yeah I've
only obviously been here for a short
time but when you first drive up you
have the immediate response of oh that's
a modern house and you can imagine that
there's some crispness to it but then
when you come right in it's like the
materiality and there's a real warmth on
the inside I was feels really nice like
it feels immediately comfortable which
is there are some houses designed like
this that don't feel that way we're like
ooh wait am I allowed to touch anything
yeah your house feels very much like
and the dogs help well I have this
theory I don't know if I've ever said
this out loud but you know it's really
cool to have interesting people that
inspire me like yourself come here to do
the podcast like we've got so many cool
people come here over the years and even
before I started the podcast we would
always have interesting people here and
I feel like every person that comes
leaves like an energetic residue here
that like enhances like the like the
spiritual vortex quality of like our
living space I love that I feel good
it's a new way of thinking yeah which i
think is a that's cool I mean it helps
that like you also have like the objects
for some of the people like there's
history if people get antsy I'm gonna
play with something yeah so cool so all
right you're you're in Oregon you're
studying architecture you're playing
hoops are you guys good you know we were
okay we never made Ben C I was just
there for two years we didn't make PNC
tournament me the NIT and lost in the
first round but we got to go to Hawaii
you know the first round to that well
yeah but we weren't awesome
I mean Oregon since then what the other
part that's bad years where they were
like football and basketball well this
year we're in the sweet 16 in basketball
yeah amazing accomplishment we've had 20
wins in a row in basketball four years
since Coach Altman is there he's awesome
but football has also had an incredible
run that's been I think changed like
changed the game actually they sped up
chip Kelly who came to Oregon I don't
know if you pay attention college
football this dude came into Oregon and
completely changed the game because of
the speed at which they played and a lot
of it actually had to do with fitness
and you know more attention to wellness
and overall presence and and and so I
think he was great unfortunately he left
and then went to the NFL and has done
other stuff and but regardless I think
that that bat in the relationship with
Nike where they meet all these super
cool uniforms and equipment that also
changed my sport was they're bringing
another branding exercise I I my first
year at Oregon we had champion
so it's pretty Nike contract that's
crazy which is so weird because it's
like you know Nike has been tied but it
just you see it's like business can
either work or not you know there wasn't
a relationship at that time and then my
second year was the first year of like
the Nike allsports contract concept and
so we got like some pretty basic
Nike stuff uh-huh and then following
years are just like like all the coolest
Nike gear was all or again you know
super cool you know colors and you could
get any shoes you want not so I missed
on that but I'm planning to get back in
on that somehow maybe this podcast will
help do you stay connected to the
basketball team a little bit I mean not
not not not specifically i watch but I
have it you know it's tough time I would
love to go to more games but if they
make it to the Final Four this year then
I want to go now that your son's a
player yeah that's a big part of it he
really starts to appreciate college
basketball just now he's a big NBA fan
but he's just starting to get out of the
Knicks that's an exercise and so the
Knicks are tough
he's become a 50-50 Nets Knicks fan so
that the nets are great this year right
not great but they're good they're a
great team to watch and they're fun and
they're in a good direction so we'll see
you about the Knicks all right so you
then go to Japan right so what was that
about well it's interesting because I
intended to move to New York City like
that was my dream uh-huh you know I
wanted to move to New York I'd not sure
why for exactly but I just knew that was
the stage that I want to worth a big
life yeah that was something like that
was a place to get to and had the plan
saved up some money but my friend is
living in Tokyo my one of my best
childhood friends is living there and I
think well I graduated from school I
should at least go visit him in Tokyo
and and and that would be a waste to not
go there while he's there so I go to
visit him and I buy like a two-week
train ticket to go travel around Japan
and stuff and I had studied Japanese
architecture side like I wanted to see
the sights and all that I get there and
literally even in the first couple days
we hatched the idea to start this
website to like connect people to
connect people learning English as a
second language to Americans who could
help them understand American culture
because no one knew what scrubs meant so
funny like to launch a business based on
like a term like scrubs but it was like
no scrubs was the TLC song that was
super popular and people would ask that
like what's a scrub and it's like it
takes a lot of nuance to be able to
explain what that is but we thought
there was business in there it turned
out to be effectively you know looking
back on it like a social network for
people who are learning English as a
second language they didn't have that
term back then you know community
websites existed but anyway so he
started that and it was very small but
it actually got some traction enough to
give us the idea of like wow we can
start a real company with this and so we
went on that journey of like starting a
company and raising some funding and
being a start-up tech startup and in
Portland we moved back from Japan to
Portland and and it became a great
little business um it didn't like
explode you know it didn't have the like
a huge growth that but it became like a
profitable business and you know when
actually my friend continued to operate
for 14 15 years but you just had this
poll to go to New York in the back of
your mind every year I like recorded out
of them yeah I mean every year I was
like is this my last year and I think I
was there for four years before I left
and and and I was almost you know five
years actually and then I was almost 30
and I was like I got a you know 30 was
like the deadline yeah and you're having
it you haven't even started in
architecture career yet yeah and I also
felt like I was to be honest like I
always said I'm never gonna be that
first of all I said I never would be the
guy never be the guy who goes to
University of Oregon cuz that's my
hometown and that's lame and I do that
and I think I'm never gonna be one of
those people just like moves to Portland
after school because that's lame too and
I was like that guy a hundred percent
and but so I told myself I'm gonna be
out before I'm 30 and so I made it to
New York the month before my 30th
birthday mm-hmm
yeah and it's kind of a cool story too
because you were trying to get a job at
these architecture firms while you were
still in Portland oh yeah yeah well it's
funny now to look back on
because now I feel like oh I'm
accomplished in the world and stuff but
back then I'm like I was literally
nobody like to the extent of in the
architecture world like I was a really
good zero experiment then I'm out five
years and I'm literally nothing like my
resume doesn't have anything applicable
so I'm like I'm not even you know I'm
not so applying for jobs it's like I'm
like you know I'm I'm like a business
leader sort of in Portland like people
know me a little bit I've been in the
newspaper you know now like trying to
get a job at architecture firm and it's
like the lowest of the low I can't even
get you know I'm so finally luckily this
little firm no Jordan Parnassus who
hired me like hired me $10 an hour and
like I'll take a chance on you I think
because he just needed someone who would
be like a drafts person yeah and I think
part of that also you know to be honest
there's in the architecture profession
especially at the time there are a lot
of amazingly talented designers who go
to school in the US and they come out
and the English skills are not good but
they want to work at firms and they're
incredibly talented way more talented
than I've ever been but they're missing
they they're not great communicators yet
and so for me coming in and being able
to do the role at a very low level but
actually being able to like communicate
really effectively as a like as I was as
a business leader gave me a different
kind of position and so when it came to
the American Apparel projects which we
were focused on I had a different
presence there than people who were just
great designers I just showed up
differently right because you were able
to communicate with these guys at a
higher level than just some young kid
right out of school yeah and also
someone who like had the appreciation
for design but also new business you
know and new so American Apparel when I
got there was in the earliest stages of
their retail development so and you know
there was some cool whatever-you-call-it
culture behind them yeah I mean people
forget like at that moment it was a big
deal like they were those billboards
were you know insanely provocative there
was just tons of you know news about it
you know Ryan talks about it all the
time and then you have Dov who's just
like this insane character that probably
well time to time yeah but even more
than that they also were trying to do
they were bringing manufacturing back to
you
they were trying to maintain a good wage
they were like giving English classes
and massages on the job you know they
were trying to compensate people fairly
so there was a good like foundation to
that from a sort of ethical perspective
it's you know as weird that I've had
those two sides of being like really
caring but then also being so outlandish
in a way but yeah it felt good like it
felt like a good thing to be a part of
at the time so you're at this tiny to a
2 or 3 architect firm and then this
contract just lands in the lap of you
guys to build the first American Apparel
store and that blossoms into essentially
building like a lot of them right yes
I'm like not also it was a little bit
split because they had the West Coast
team who needed a lot of the East Plus
International so we were a part of a
growth path that went from early handful
of stores to at some points you know
maybe 40 to 50 concurrent projects
happening around that escalation was
really fast yeah I mean one of the
factory tail rollouts
I had to be a pressure cooker it you
know it's interesting like dove is such
a cool character because of the things
that he cared about you know he really
cared about lighting for example like he
really cared about about lights and the
color of lights and stuff so it was just
like you know some some things he cared
about was schedule and time and stuff
but there are some moments I had with
him where he's like what the [ __ ] are
these lights get these all out of here
and literally it's like every one hand
all hands on deck you have to like bill
unscrew every light bulb and change it
to a different bulb like on demand just
because there were things you know that
he really liked he was in the details
you know of some things like that and um
and I like appreciated that like there
were times when I really thought he was
an [ __ ] to be honest but I also
really thought he was doing something
good and I think that was okay to me
like I felt like it was like okay
trade-off at least in my experience
other people I can't speak for and who
experienced probably other things but
for me being yelled at screamed at get
this done you know move faster do it
cheaper like I took that as like I'm
gonna learn from this every moment
rather than be like oh this guy's an
[ __ ] that sucks I'm gonna be like
this is a great opera
to learn from to be under this pressure
yeah and if you can get through that
then your weatherproofed for basically
anything I would say to experiences in
my life one working with of the other I
worked in Alaska and a fish processing
plant for 16 hours a day I was like
those two experiences the it doesn't
really get like you've kind of had it
all like the monotony of endless salmon
coming off the off the conveyor belt and
the like super intensity of someone
screaming at you to like do something
that's totally unreasonable outlandish I
kind of like I've always drawn on those
things as like I can handle anything
yeah and I would have to think that
being around of like there's a there's a
he's a complicated figure but there's an
audacity to his vision like he he was
shooting for the stars right like the
the the scope of what he was trying to
do was gigantic and yeah in certain
respects he was successful in
accomplishing that at least in the short
term so did that end up informing like
the big vision that you held for for we
work
I don't think consciously but I think it
definitely was inside of me in terms of
the way that I internalized like
business and vision and like you know
and really what was possible through
force of well because I'm not that kind
of person like I'm not a person who
would like scream or yell or like you
know fight for something like it's just
not in me I'm a much more reserved
person and so I think you did informed
my relationship with Adam in an
important way because I learned things
about myself like I was able to exist
with Dov not that I had that much
interaction with him but I could like
pick up the phone and hear him yell at
me mm-hmm
and be okay not personal I said right
just I was resilient in that like okay
fine I got yelled at I'm not gonna go
into a hole or into a shell I'm gonna
just keep on moving forward you know
yeah no matter what and I think that
that's like an important thing to
realize what my capabilities were in
that contract but I also knew I wasn't
him I wasn't like the person who could
drive people like that I couldn't be I
was really laid back you know like I'm
like
oregan dude right like you're a chill
dude
with the design chops and the attention
to detail but then Adam has like this
charisma and this like relentless
persistence right that makes for a great
combination yeah and a kind of drive
that was way different than mine in
terms of like just non-stop energy you
know that like willing to just like
everyday be at like max you know and
that's something that I give him so much
credit for because he's still that way
the keys still you know literally can
just he you know he's non-stop like in
some cases it's like you need him out of
seven rather than a ten because he can
relate better to like normal people out
of seven you know he knows that he's
developed is a modular now yeah it's
early days it might be like all ten oh
yeah like that's how you ended up with
those early leases right yeah I mean and
that's what I mean again going back to
like how do you how are we successful
early on amazing formula of Adam being
able to push and convince and really
through force of personality get people
to do stuff that they didn't want to do
and then me to be able to back that up
like immediately like really to be able
to turn that around and like make
something credible really fast so that
it seems like we're nobody to someone
and then literally we're someone you
know the next day he can spin the yarn
and then you have to fulfill on the
promise which I had no I never told him
to like slow down I've never told him
not to make a promise or anything like
I've never said well what would have
been thinking in my head like dude why
are you saying way ahead of yourself
here why are you promising that we'll do
that but I didn't I don't say that
because I knew at least especially in
those early days and now it's obviously
a way larger team but in the early days
it was my job to back that up yeah you
know and obviously he's a part of that
as well but I'm just saying the the
formula is like he's gonna push us and
I'm gonna figure out how to fulfill you
know that that space that he would
create and and it was I think it was
a really powerful formula like it really
was however it happened it was special
well I want to get to how it happened so
you're you're building all these stores
these retail outlets for American
Apparel like why not just ride that out
and stay there and be this way yeah I
mean there's something there in terms of
like you know how many times can you do
the same thing and certainly with
American Apparel we did a lot of the
same thing and for me I mean I really
look for the challenge the opportunity
to grow and again I probably won't have
used those words then but it's the
choices I made reflect the fact that I'm
like always looking for the next way to
and the growth curve starts to Plateau
yeah you start looking around and I get
bored super fast like I get some of the
suit I figure something I love teaching
myself stuff but once I learned it I'm
like okay like that was cool but now I
need something else and so I think with
American Apparel I just hit the end I
was like I can't do another one you know
and it wasn't changing really like it
was just the same the the first seeable
future looked the same and so I did a
few kind of projects that were outside
of American Apparel and and at that
point I just needed a different scene
and so but but at the time where we were
was a cool community that firm was in a
building in Brooklyn and Dumbo that was
like meet-up of like cool small
companies and like you know if the Bible
was great
like in trash neighborhood is amazing
yeah and it's really gotten like even
better you know I mean you can complain
about whatever real-estate prices that's
always the you know places like cool
when it's rough and then it gets better
and then it gets expensive and all that
but but it's a cool energy there and so
I convinced Adam to move into that same
building and how did you meet Adam so
Gail was my friend at work who's an
Israeli guy and oh very similar to me
like very chill dude you know and so we
became friends and we're sitting next to
each other at the office and you know I
don't I don't know that many people I'm
still relatively new to New York and he
says hey what are you do
weekend I'm like honestly come over to
our apartment we're like hanging out
uh-huh and so I like walking to this
building you know it's on Broadway and
like were Street in Manhattan and I mean
remember it clearly because like we came
on and like I forget what floor maybe
we're on the elevator go up a floor too
and doors open an Adam comes on and Adam
is like no I'm a tall dude I'm six foot
eight he's six foot four or whatever
sixty-five something and he's no shirt
on shorts no shoes and like just beaming
energy just like you know like he's like
a buzz and then he's like actually
literally buzzing and just talking
nonstop and I don't even know I can't
remember a word he's saying I just know
he's talking to everyone on the elevator
and I you know a New York elevator is
usually not filled with conversation
yeah you know especially amongst people
who don't know each other and this is
his apartment building so he knows
people who live there and he's he and
his sister I think I've like tried to
build community like they've actually
been living in the building for a while
so they've tried to like get people to
know each other and they talked to
everyone and everything but I don't know
this you know I don't know the history
of their existence so to me I'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on this is so
weird and so um the the key moment of
like my like whoa was that we're all on
the elevator now no there's four or five
of us and he's talking to someone and
that person walks off the elevator and
he holds the door and just continues the
conversation as they're like walking
down the hall and I remember just
standing there going like where there's
other people in the elevator
yes it's like like that the self
confidence in the poise that that
requires yeah like just not like I've
never like it seems so small but yeah
it's so big from a he knows you
everything to be like like that is an
audacious thing to do because it's just
not done you know it's like the kind of
thing it's like you're breaking all
social norms in that situation you know
I didn't even that I certainly don't do
that kind of stuff I'm like way more
like I'm quietly care about everyone I'm
like I have like the Japanese like
ideals of keeping everything calm and
you know so I remember that clearly
because that whole day turned an
experience of like us hanging out and
you know feeling a lot of trepidation
and discomfort but then
knowing that I needed that or that I was
interested in her and that was really
the thing I mean I think if you go to
like what was i searching for in New
York I wanted things that were foreign
to me things that mean you feel
uncomfortable things that were hard I
wasn't looking for an easy life I was
looking for the things that would like
be you know not Portland not you journey
and so what is that we're just not to
interrupt you but like where do you
where does that what's the genesis of
that like where does that come from that
like drive that energy you know it's a
good question I I've always had a
feeling that that I could be a part of
something different and I know that just
sounds weird but it's like I've always
first seen myself doing things in a way
that everyone else around me wasn't
doing them mm-hmm so like if you look at
going back to like architecture school
for example it doesn't sound crazy now
to say that I love Frank Gehry
but in my entire class as well as almost
the whole school at the time there was
like one other kid who even like really
knew who he was you know and that was
like my like all in you know love of the
of architecture was based on that so you
know when I did my first projects my
first design looked nothing like all the
other kids and I was willing to stand in
front of that and present it comfortably
for some reason like that was just I
knew that was me
like I knew I just wouldn't be the same
as everyone else and I don't know what's
weird about that as it goes counter to
my actual physical presence which has
always been again being bigger than
normal and especially as a kid when I
was fat I was always trying to receive
of always trying to be like in the
background like I always wanted no one
to notice me and I spent a lot of time
at other people's houses because you
know I didn't have boys as friends and
so I was at my friends houses a lot my
male friends and um you know I would get
criticized for like eating too much I'm
like a big fat
of course you know why are you having
three slices of pizza you know like that
kind of stuff happened to me so I think
that I often tried to like disappear in
those scenarios and yet for some reason
when I got to this other place I just
developed this comfort with always being
the like outlier like always just trying
to do something different and I'm not
sure I don't know why exactly I just did
just switched at some time and I think
that it came I don't know and it came
from just an unwillingness to like you
know as soon as people got jobs and buy
houses and cars and TVs and I was just
like that whoa like I'll never be that
that guy like I'll never I mean I
obviously now have some of those things
but like you know I just I don't know
right just the same way I couldn't
follow the same path it just I just
couldn't right and then you collide with
this shirtless dynamo and you're like
this guy's my my ticket to you know I
continue my path to being this
iconoclast again I don't know I think I
don't know when you know that
realization happened obviously like that
day I was just like ooh something's
going on there that it's different and
over time I think the the bond that we
built was when he moved into the
building and then we were both there and
we were both very hard workers in the
sense that we're like putting in the
extra hours and stuff is that we spent a
lot of time just like walking around the
neighborhood you know and just talking
about stuff and trying to like feel each
other out I think you know and and
realizing that we had like real
differences but somehow we both
developed an appreciation for each other
and I you know it's hard to say why like
I don't know why there was in some way
like some kind of attraction or you know
magnetism that happened there but what
do you think that he saw in you you know
I don't know for sure but what I would
think is that he hasn't he didn't have a
to that point a lot of stability in his
life he had a lot of people in his life
that were very you know like family and
other conditions that you know weren't
consistent that weren't calm you know if
he was on this right cycle you could
ground him yeah I probably had some kind
of consistent energy you know and I
think when he would search me out
sometimes you know maybe that's why I
mean maybe it's like he wanted to
connect to some of that some of that
more consistency and I hope that you
know I hope that um that that was like I
I mean again we we don't we haven't
talked about it that much but I do hope
that that was like was what I felt it
was you know which is yeah I would
imagine your your your you're seeing in
each other things that you don't have or
that you aspire to have or that you need
in your life right this is like
perfectly complimentary in yin and yang
thing yeah and it didn't really have
purpose at all that sort of thing to is
it wasn't like it started out with like
hey we're gonna do business together it
wasn't like that it was just something
else it was like you know whether it was
friendship or whether it was just
we're both sharing an energy with each
other that we needed not clear you know
it wasn't like there was a specific
reason for us being together and
spending that time together but it but
it was something that we both just we
had we needed so he he moves into your
office building and he's doing his
entrepreneurial thing with like baby
clothes or something right right yeah so
when is the idea like hey let's do
something together kind of enter the
picture well so we started talking about
some different projects that were like
you know at the time of the like
residential explosion around the world
but also in Manhattan there was a ton of
people it's kind of like the dot-com era
where it's like well everybody's
developing real estate you know and so
we looked at some like residential
projects and we had that in mind like
hey we could do something this spot that
spot but it wasn't again it wasn't
formal it wasn't like we had really had
a partnership or anything it was just
like these different projects seemed
interesting and huh and what really I
mean he had
in his in school when he was in school
he did a project that was related to
like community housing and like this
idea that you could create something
more connective and he had been exposed
to this co-working model that someone
else was doing in New York
I hadn't really ever seen co-working
before like I saw the environments in
Brooklyn where there was a lot of these
small companies working together but I
didn't know formally what this was and
so he said to me one day like hey we
could do a co-working space like he
looked at the economics of this building
and they were charging a very low rent
and basically no service as you know
just like in Dumbo yeah and Dumbo here's
the landlord of the building where it's
like hey here's this space you can have
it take it or leave it you know not very
good marketing or sales not good
customer service so he had the idea of
like hey we can make this kind of like
this serviced office model that he had
seen before and so I went and and he was
trying to convince the landlord that we
could do this but the landlord is like
you have a baby clothing company I don't
even know who this other guy is so but
they just didn't care they're like doing
fine they have like a good business
they're renting out space so it's like
it's not they were their space was in
demand even though they're charging a
low price for it they didn't need us for
anything so Adam really did a good job
of like continually going back and at
the same time I was hatching some ideas
of of what could it be if we actually
did this like if we did a like shared
office and so I went and saw a couple of
the things that were called that at the
time and they were horrible in my my
design view mm-hmm I'm like these places
suck at the time where they just open
floor plans with long term you know
absolutely the opposite the places that
the big mistake in and I forget the name
I'm it's escaping out there there was a
company that was emerging in New York
who is doing something that was like
co-working in shared office and to me
they made a really fatal mistake which
is that they put a lot of their money
into their newest coolest location and
it was a long skinny building with
windows only on the ends and then they
built these
custom partitions which were kind of
like modern cubicle and they were all
black and they were solid and so you
come into this place it's all dark they
actually had like Club they were in the
club scene so they had like club music
playing it was super dark and they have
black partitions that absorb all the
light and the windows are only you know
far and I went into that place and I was
like I wouldn't spend five minutes in
here yeah let alone what I was looking
for which was like this is should be
amazing like you should feel so good
when you walk into this place like that
was the whole point so when I saw that I
was like okay we can do something way
way way better than this and and so that
started to come into my head of like
what are we what would we do if we got
the chance and by you know coincidence
Adam finally you know gets the landlord
to like say okay here's a building what
would you do with it
and that was like the hinge point
because I think when we finally got the
opportunity we and we hadn't really
formalized anything but we got the
chance to turn that into you know a
really quick business model brand which
was not we work that was green dust
before right but green desk was oriented
towards environmental responsibility and
and turning that around really quickly I
think gave us that initial credibility
like okay you were nobody today
yesterday and now you're somebody right
so Adam person you know just pesters
this guy enough until he finally relents
and then you guys are suddenly in the
position that's like alright I guess
we're gonna do this right and like
bootstrapping this thing literally
overnight you got to make it happen I
mean how did you even have was it a
whole building well it started as just
one floor so the beautiful little
building in DUMBO that made you even
finance that well so luckily and this is
part of the you know again the the being
in the right place at the right time was
that these owners of the property they
had this building was super cool
beautiful windows you know timber brick
and timber you know kind of the ideal
like it was old like Karki warehouse you
know and loft yeah exactly
and they say you know what would you do
with that well
we come back with like the design ideas
looks really cool who's gonna pay for it
and we made you know we made a
partnership with them and they paid for
it and we designed it built it run it
they paid for the build-out so it became
50/50 from that so yeah in partnership
with the owners of the building yeah
right and so then from there we were
very successful I mean literally like we
put tape down on the floor sewing these
are the spaces and we had renderings of
what its gonna look like and we started
selling it and people loved it right off
the bat and so we knew we were onto
something from the first floor built it
out filled up another floor another
floor another floor and I mean we're
doing much better I mean so even their
return on you know their 50% was way
more than they're getting on their
normal rent so they could see this
something cool they like it they'll
continue to build it out as we went so
we did that whole building and then we
started doing floors and that other
original building that we had been in
and so it was clear that it was
something but the real hinge point in
terms of Adam and I was that we won I
forget if the building was full maybe we
had mostly filled it up but were like
we're gonna have like a party for the
first time uh-huh and we bring everyone
together and like I literally think like
we looked on the internet for like
networking techniques or whatever and
there was this like speed networking
thing where it's like you know you make
two lines and then you each do talk to
you personally seconds and then you
shift and it sounds like so cheesy and
we didn't know what we were doing but
like that spawned a lot of people then
more organically and casually
interacting that evening and then the
next day literally just that elevator
ride felt different and then the whole
workspace felt different because before
everyone was kind of in their own office
even though it was glass they had
familiarity but they weren't really
connecting on on the level that we
noticed they were after that night right
and not really like shifted something
where we we we then felt like whoa this
is what it's all about like seeing the
people who need each other so much in
this context like small business people
entrepreneurs you know freelancers
people who are trying to start something
new what they really need is that like
connection they need the opportunity to
like have someone else who's in the same
boat because your family doesn't you
know you've experienced it like when
you're working hard sometimes you got to
get away from your family you know you
got to get out and so you leave your
apartment you're on your own you're
working really hard no one gets it why
are you doing this why did you quit your
job now all these other stories that
come with that adventure and what you
really need is a community of people
that are supportive in that construct
and so that was from that moment we're
like okay green desk was wrong it's
something new
we got a sort of start over right so
well a couple things in that I mean
first just the idea that you had to okay
we're gonna have a party and we're gonna
try to get these people together speaks
to you know that you know core value of
community that that existed at the
inception so I presume
Adam shared that you know that vision
and that value I mean did he you ain't
grow up in a comm unit he's Israeli
right like did he live in a like a
similar kind of experience that gave him
that same yeah so I mean he had
experience as in a kibbutz but I also
think he had the like being a part of a
community in New York as well I know of
just like you got to depend on people
you know you get somewhere new yeah
you're out in a new city who are you
gonna rely on finding people that like
you can actually count on and building a
group of people that you know you can
spend time with and he's a great he
loves like hospitality he loves bringing
people together he loves being a host I
mean something that he takes great pride
in and and he actually will you know
when he does it privately he worked
super hard at like bringing people
together and making it a great
experience and so he has that motivation
of really like he he wants those
experiences to be deeper you know he
doesn't want you to just like you don't
show up at the party because it's just
the cool place to be you show up because
you're actually getting something from
it and he cares about that and he did
from the start and so it was like that
combination of like I wanted to make
this
space where this is like persistent like
we're gonna make me design these spaces
where that connection is possible any
moment and he was much more of like the
peak moment it's like that's what he
would be like when we do a party it's
gonna be the best party you know or we
bring people together it's gonna be like
the best thing they've ever been to and
he you know so and Eve as we've evolved
then we've gotten into like our summer
camp events and you know our summit
events and stuff like that like a lot of
that motivation is for him of really
wanting to bring people together and
then to make it awesome you know make it
amazing so you have this inflection
point because this real estate partner
that you have they have your your
interests begin to diverge because they
basically just want you to focus on
their buildings right and you could have
said okay filled their buildings and had
like a really nice business yeah just
said you know and maybe kind of inch
your way out of that other buildings
once you had filled those to capacity
but instead you take you you you know
you do this risky move where you break
up with this partner and that all goes
back to this like bigger vision that you
held yeah there was a couple moments in
there where I remember when we finished
the first building and like if we would
have just stopped there good we would
have been like the most money I would
have ever had yeah you know like just in
the monthly income like I was like we
were all like wow this is actually
pretty good and then when we sold we
also had a moment like that where we
were like you know we had a chunk of
money that we could have right like wow
you put that in the bank and our third
partner share in partner Gill who did
that who you know went back to Israel
and you know said this was a achievement
and and um but Adam and I just
immediately mean Adam even said to me he
was like don't put that money in my bank
account
just keep it you know or put it
somewhere else because I know you know
I'll spend it if I have access to it but
he he was like we're letting it ride for
sure so it was never even a question
yeah not a question that it was we're
just you know at the beginning of this
and we we put all that money that we got
into the
start of the next thing and I think from
the very beginning that was because we
knew it was big like it wasn't like oh
we're gonna do another version of green
desk where we could like be comfortable
and like where we make money that that
never came in - it wasn't like oh we hit
on a good business model like let's make
you know I mean like we knew at that
moment that this is like okay something
way bigger it's not gonna be about like
our individual financial success this is
a part of a way way way way bigger right
but then you have the practicality of
like trying to get the you know what's
gonna be the first new building and what
has now been rebranded as we work right
like you're still too young guys you got
a little bit of money but yeah these are
I mean this is you know this is capital
intensive and it's also New York real
estate yes you know it's like where no
one you know like family and credit and
all these things madam you know Asian
ships which we knew nobody but you did
have one thing that happened which is in
2008 like the market turned right so
suddenly there's there's vacancy where
there didn't used to be and there's not
as much demand yeah so two things I mean
there's that part which is there's
vacancy there's less demand there's less
like new tenants coming around the
corner so a landlord who wants to wait
that out doesn't have a clear path for
one but then - there was some difference
at least in the argument of what like a
credit tenant is right cuz you you were
thinking that like Lehman Brothers is
like a credit tenant at the time you
know right like you think that's not a
company that's going down that's a
rock-solid you know and then a lot of
the companies like that mmm maybe not at
Lehman Brothers level but at lower
levels were effectively defaulted on
leases so we could at least say hey that
was the old way like were the new way
and and I don't think anyone believed it
but at least it was like gave them a
little bit of comfort you know and like
in our story and we we had a lot of
buildings that we put a lot of time into
that then didn't work out because when
the boss heard about it it was like no
way like the whoever the real estate
management
was like yeah these guys are cool
they're doing some interesting and then
the boss heard about he was like no
that's a stupid idea you know we never
rent to those kind of people you know is
there ever a moment where you thought
maybe this isn't gonna work or was Adam
just so persistent yeah I don't my I
mean my brain doesn't really work that
way uh-huh
I don't usually that work well I think
it's more like always moving forward
with some level of I don't know like
confidence that if we're doing something
that's good it's gonna work out you know
and so I don't remember ever having any
question about that but I also don't
think we had much down time to worry
about it was like even though the deals
weren't coming through the you know Adam
was like creating the deal flow where it
was always the next one and the next one
the next one is like we're producing for
each one of those were negotiating the
lease we're producing some you know
sketch version of what the buildings
gonna look out look like how much our
income could be so we're kind of
test-fitting all those projects before
we so I wasn't like we're just sitting
around going like what's gonna happen
we're pretty much in it waiting for like
the domino to fall you know and then
what was the break that led to the first
building well that's a it's weird cuz
you know this is a business but there
was a lot of emotion that went into it
back then and the first building was a
building owner who I have loved and
something opposite for because he did
take a chance on us but he also I would
say tortured us to some extent by just
fighting every single term of the lease
you know who just being so intense as a
negotiator and a arguer and a
person who like felt like every term was
life and death for him and this is the
way some of the people I mean this is a
man who you know his family escaped
Syria went through like serious stuff
like he thinks of that building as it's
part of his life and his family's future
so I don't begrudge him that but at the
same time like the fight for every
millimeter of that deal was in hours and
hours and hours of of arguing and and
for me that's not I don't enjoy that
like maybe some people love that
negotiation now looking back thinking
like that was one of the more difficult
leases that you ever had to negotiate
does it feel all the sweeter no no no it
doesn't because it was it was really
hard for me like it was hard emotionally
and then you know and there were other
layers of difficulty once we started
building out that building because if
you look at like just the least then
imagine now we're trying to build and
it's like there's issue after issue in
the building and now you have to argue
about who pays for this unexpected cost
I mean there was so much time and energy
arguing and fighting that it took a lot
out of me which I wish I could look back
on it fondly but to be honest like I
wanted that learning curve right I
didn't make you bulletproof for the next
go-around yeah III you know it did but
in some ways but it also there is that
building when I walked by it and I loved
that it's the foundation of the company
but I honestly like I it I feel
something that feels painful uh-huh it's
the one is it in Soho yeah it's
Lafayette and grand and I love it it's
like where we started it's an amazing
building it's great for the members
there but to be honest it's hard for me
to like walk through a half um but I
should add also and this is an important
part of the equation is that my son who
is the exact same ager we work was also
was born at the same time that this was
happening so I was in the most intense
phase of both of those things and so
that was you know I didn't sleep for a
long time and I was
you know so it um I think it was a lot
of things that had luck and again I'm
not I mean we made it through it it's
great but it was hard it was super super
super hard from an emotional perspective
and I mean add to that it's a start-up
where we didn't have we spent the money
to build the building every month we
were on the hook for the rent you know
and I believe that if we defaulted that
was someone who would like take the
building back it wasn't someone who's
good oh no problem and pay me next month
you know so I watched the bank account
every day and like was always like like
making sure like I got it when we get to
that month make sure that we've done all
the stuff right with the money so we
have you know that we pay on time right
amount
was it a similar experience with that
you had with with green desk though
where you you know we're being able to
fill subscriptions like oh yeah and you
just knew you knew like this is this
concept works and that was the balance
like we were it was so great in the
building from the beginning and we had
this we had an amazing community team
from the start Lisa and Nathan who are
the first community management team and
they were incredible at bringing people
together and also the members that we
had from the early days were awesome so
you it was both sides that's what was so
interesting about it was that there was
so much fulfillment in this like what
you've got from the energy of being in
the building and then this other side of
like wow it's hard to make this work
every day and but I mean it was all
worth it for sure right as it is as a
designer as an architect when you're
faced with the proposition of a
build-out you're looking at a floor plan
and it's up to you to figure out how do
I create a roadmap a design a structure
a flow that is conducive to promoting
these values that I care about like how
do you think about that and then break
that down and kind of implement that
into a physical space well first of all
it's definitely been an evolution a long
evolution that we're still you know
learning from and trying to figure out
but
there were a couple of things that I
actually they seemed so basic but like
the first thing I felt like was that you
want people who feel happy because if we
run into each other at the coffee
machine or whatever if we're happy we're
gonna have a good interaction if one of
us is like feeling like [ __ ] that day
either we're not gonna speaker I'm gonna
like drag you down or vice versa
right so so there was this fundamental
thing of how do you get a feeling of
like wow this piece feels good and for
me in architecture school it was like
daylight was always a big part of that
so first thing we had was every building
will be on a corner so there's two sides
of light minima you know obviously a
free-standing building is even better
but it was like we're never gonna take a
building that doesn't have great light
and that it's democratized where it's
like everyone gets some of that it's not
like the people next to the window get
it and then everyone's else's in the
dark so that plus making everything
glass which was kind of like a to make a
dumb idea in in in at the time in the
sense that it was so basic but when I
was in like psych 101 at Colorado
College we learned just about
familiarity and they said that like
people who are familiar with each other
are more likely to be friendly with each
other people actually like like find
people more attractive who they're
familiar with you know there's all these
benefits of familiarity so I thought if
everything's glass and everyone can see
each other that will over time build up
the chance it's like if we've seen each
other's face eight times but we've never
spoken well now we happen to see each
other on the elevator out in the wild
you know at a restaurant
oh I know you like you're the guy from
down the hall right so that familiarity
would over time we build up this
potential for a connection and then you
know from there we learn to try to
create spaces that were actually
designed we call it center of gravity
but space is where sort of all paths
lead to the same place
because at the time there was a lot of
residential was getting to be
competitive and there was a lot of these
cool buildings where they made awesome
right like you put on the roof or second
floor the awesome gym and like the big
TV and the pool table and you'd go into
these places there's literally no one
there ever right so it's like they're
doing something wrong there they're
spending all this money to make the
amenity which check sums box some box
like when you whatever rent or buy but
then it has no value beyond that so what
we wanted to figure out is like there's
obviously a good intent but it's
something's missing so how can we create
a way that you just naturally flow and
that to me became something I'm still
really curious about which is just
thresholds and how we make decisions
about things because obviously we don't
always make decisions that are good for
us right even though we might think like
oh yeah it would be great to go hang out
in the common area if you have to like
get on an elevator and go up six floors
yeah probably not gonna do it you know
like you're just lazy
for the most part mentally even like
regardless of like the energy to walk
there it's often time you're just
mentally lazy to make the decision so
the idea was to remove threshold
conditions where you don't ever have a
decision you just flow like you just
happened on your way to it's on your way
to wherever you're going by the way and
then that just happens in that you have
a lot of different places to go so let's
try to make those let's try to make
those spaces multifunctional and then
let's try to present a lot of options in
those spaces because you know all there
are great speakers who speak out we work
all the time if I get the email saying
cool speaker 4 o'clock I'm not gonna go
like put that on my calendar I'm gonna
go to the speaker maybe once in a while
but a lot of time I'm gonna be like even
though I signed up I'm too busy to go
but if I just happen to be walking by
and I'm like oh wait who's that
uh-huh oh that's cool pause listen for a
few minutes wow this is actually really
interesting you know this is cool maybe
I'll hang out and linger longer then I
can like accidentally be connected to
something that could actually have a
really interesting effect on me and so
that's been a really like there are a
lot of those things where it's like it's
actually annoying in both cases
for the people to have to have the
speaker in the space because there's
always people wandering around and
and you know versus an auditorium where
it's like everyone's closed up and then
on the same on the other side it's like
if you're in your office and there's a
speaker it could be annoying because
like but those are some of the risks we
are willing to take of like right let's
you know have the speaker let's play the
World Cup game in the common area even
though there's gonna be some people and
we still get the emails like so stupid
why is there a soccer game on in the
common area I'm trying to work you know
yeah but those are the trade-offs in
like the overall net benefit which we
believe yeah you're annoyed and you
trying to make your phone call and and
you know we understand but overall it
goes back to the same thing everything's
glass what are the first people who come
in do first thing can I cover the glass
almost everybody all right can't cover
the glass because if I let you cover it
then the next person come in they want
to cover it too and soon we've
completely lost that benefit that was
fundamental to that there's gotta be
instances in which people do want to
have a private meeting right yeah and we
want to provide that there's a bunch of
functions we want to provide for us so
that's and that's a big part of a
revolution is how do we actually make
spaces that are supportive of lots of
different work types and that could be
like the phone booth which we added
probably in building two or three
because we knew people need a private
conversation or it could be the Nook
which is one of the most popular little
spaces for two people to hang out you
know or we've evolved conference rooms
over times to have different sizes and
shapes and you know we added boardrooms
if you didn't have in the beginning we
added classrooms and you know now we
have in some buildings meditation rooms
so it's like we're continuously evolving
that collection of supportive functions
and we're still working on it we're
still trying to figure it out well I
think that at least in Los Angeles and
perhaps in a location or two in New York
you should have a dedicated soundproof
studio space for people to do a podcast
I mean everybody's a creator right yeah
all these youtube everyone's creating
their audio-visual content in one form
or another particularly in this town and
certain other towns but you know that is
a trend right yeah and and I've been
i've done podcasts in in in various we
work conference rooms and i'm like they
should just have like one room that you
can reserve that is quieter than the
right yeah you guys go do that okay well
let me explain that one a little bit I
can't be the first person to so first of
all not building number two in New York
Empire State opened with a screening
room literally the second building we
had open with a screening room and a
recording studio to support these
functions and then first building in
Hollywood had editing Suites and
screening room and said yeah so cool but
you people who record podcasts you start
to get a little specific about the
things that you need not everyone wants
the same thing you know like you have
your lights and like your camera setup
and then there's some technical need
that you have that this doesn't fulfill
and now we need our own manager of that
technology in those spaces one and we
also need in some way a different sales
function because we're used to selling
work space and you want a podcast room
right so I don't we don't have a
dedicated person who knows how to
connect to and sell to so we make these
spaces they're fine I think they're not
perfect and then we don't have a person
or we don't have a separate website for
the person who needs a podcast recording
studio right like so sounds really
simple we're still working on it how do
you think about the nature of work
itself I mean I would imagine you put a
lot of thought into this because this is
the business that you're in and we're in
a situation in which the tectonic plates
of you know what the work place is what
it looks like what it means to
quote-unquote like go to work are really
in flux so how does you know what is the
philosophy that you hold around that
like where do you see it going and matiz
the future of work work is the harder
part what we need as humans as people as
social beings I think is the part that
we think we can play a really important
part of so regardless of whether there's
displacement by AI or efficiency or
other efficient systems or robots who
or or perhaps even just you know the
ways that people are effective and
efficient in their own you know weight
waving they work like if their if their
knowledge or brainpower is the most
important thing and they don't need that
for as many hours as other day as we
currently think of it who knows what
that how that will change but what we
feel really confident is that we need
this like we need the human connection
of being face-to-face and spending time
with other people so I think that we're
gonna keep building that social
emotional communal communitarian
infrastructure to be supportive of
whatever those work models evolved to be
right because they'll continue to change
over time but we know that like what
happens next to that will continue to be
really important so when you look at
something like Flatiron school like
Flatiron school really awesome school
they're amazing at teaching students in
real life and we're able to add
community to that and it's great but
it's not and it's like we can do a lot
of locations but it still won't be
scalable to the masses right but
Flatiron as an online learning program
can actually be effective because we can
take the people who are learning online
and create that community and support
that community of those learners in a
whole bunch of different places where we
don't have an actual fizzle physical
location of a school right so I think
that's where education may be changing
work might be changing you know the way
we eat is changing lots of things are
evolving but your respect always know we
still need to be able to connect with ya
there in real life and we need to get
way way way better at that like we're
still doing it out of at a minimal rate
right we're still there's still so few
of us who have one hour of a day where
we feel like that fulfillment of
connection now huge emerging part of our
business is working with large companies
to do to create a similar environment of
openness of connection of creativity of
innovation because that's what all the
companies are
where that me me at all a lot of them
like a large company would contact you
and say help us figure out how to
reconfigure our yes base yeah exactly
they have to change they have to change
their workplace they have to change
their culture they have to change the
way it feels to work at that company and
so we're really excited to be a part of
something like that because if they
don't they just continue to do this the
same way they've always done it right
and we know that's not the righteous
half where the four although or a few
time antiquated and they'll just they'll
fight they'll fight really hard to keep
doing it the way that's been done right
and they you know they'll do that
because their shareholders will require
it of them up into a certain point right
but at the same time they need to be a
part of the solution right and we
believe we can help we believe we can be
a part of that kind of transformation so
you guys have recently embarked on this
we live initiative where now you're
creating living spaces what do you have
them in like New York and DC yeah New
York and DC they've been around for a
couple years we're gonna we have one in
Seattle that will open soon and they're
like studios or all the way up to like
literally almost like communal living
spaces with multiple bedrooms around a
shared living space and how does it work
yeah I mean we're still in the ones that
we have there are you know I believe up
to four bedroom units or four beds and
we're you know we're really
experimenting with that on multiple
levels because that in different regions
there are different ways you know that
code allows you to do different things
so in New York there are moderate
restrictions although they're the
government's actually working on
involving that but um you know we're
trying to apply some of those same
principles like again there's something
about residential where it's like you
know you feel in an apartment you enter
the building go up in the elevator the
hall is empty a bunch of closed doors go
in your apartment and that's it you
don't have any connective tissue there's
nothing that draws you in so ideally we
would create some of those same
environments that are threshold free or
with reduced threshold so you just flow
into other potential connections and are
they all
in the in buildings where you have we
work office spaces well yeah yeah yeah
integrated so it's almost like in the
way that Apple created this ecosystem
I mean closed-off is the wrong
connotation but like kind of this world
in which you can inhabit this is feels
like a similar thing like you can enter
the Wii the Wii will you've read what's
the new name that you guys are really
company a weak company experience to
live to work to eat to workout or
whatever it is which is like that's like
that's like I mean talk about like big
vision that's like a huge vision yeah um
we just had an initiative that was made
public which it was we cities initiative
and it's an entire city that you would
design an entire zoo I don't know what
it means exactly but I think if you
again there's something about it which
can be like well those people are crazy
they want yeah like take over everything
and then and I keep getting back to why
and this was part of the start of our
conversation is like what do we need to
be really good at we need to help people
in real life face to face make
connections to fight disconnection
loneliness depression plagues of our
time right so you could look at it from
the like Frank Lloyd Wright perspective
which was design everything and like
control the user and even determine what
clothes they're wearing inside of the
home that you develop right that's not
what we're trying to to promote but at
the same time we would love to have
influence on people for a really
fundamentally important reason you know
which is to increase that that
possibility yeah it's it's audacious and
it's bold but it's also beautiful
because the truth is we are starved for
that connection we're in an epidemic of
depression and
you know drug addiction and anxiety and
stress and we really are dying to be
more connected and a big kind of
contributor to this affliction is the
way that society has kind of you know
created these environments in which we
live and work right so the idea that hey
let's if you were going to design a
brand new city and it's all about it's
all gonna facilitate connectivity
connection and community like what would
that look like like there's there's yes
there's an idealism built into that but
there's also something that's pretty
cool like what would that city look like
and I can tell you some of my happiest
moments were when I was a college
student I was on a let hakeem where I
was super close to these people that I
spent a tremendous amount of time with
and then I would go back to my dorm or
these Suites where I lived or a house
that I shared with other people and we
did spend a tremendous amount of time in
these common areas and the doors were
always open and that sense of feeling
connected to other human beings in an
environment that was conducive to like
learning and growing is a really amazing
thing and I would like more of that in
my life now so when I hear about you
know we live and you could like move to
New York and like immediately tap into
like this situation that's community
oriented and then work I feel like I was
born out of time like I wish I was you
know 23 right now and I could go
experience that because I feel as an
adult you know now I don't have as much
of that in my life as I would like and I
know that I would be a happier more
fulfilled person if I did have more of
that and I know most people would as
well
everybody would right yeah well it's
weird cuz when we first started we lived
there are some almost derogatory
evaluations saying like it's dorms for
adults yeah but I kind of like I'd be
like stoked to move I'm like wow there's
some really good like right I like to
living in a dorm yeah I don't think I
mean I'm sure there are some people who
don't and there are downsides which
again with design perhaps we're going to
figure out how to reconcile but yeah
it's like the good parts of that or
like so good and also the you know the
free-flowing 'no sub like not having to
like text and plan and like okay I'll
meet you over there you know and
everything is you know kid playdates and
everything you know everything's just so
structured it's like when you're in the
dorm it's like you're just rolling
through life you know and like bumping
into people and who knows what's gonna
happen you know next and I think that's
something that like people look at that
like that's somehow an immature way of
living or something and that's weird
like it's really weird that like we
somehow created this contract where
we're like a lot growing up means go
live in a while you lay yourself off
yeah like why it's so weird and I mean
I'm sure I there's plenty of reasons why
it happened but I think now that the
problem is is that it is very hard to
change because it's actually like you
said very expensive infrastructure that
supports this way of living that we have
now yeah right so and residential is
harder than than than work and that's
one of the reasons why we've been able
to scale we work very quickly because
you know on any we work floor there's
one set of bathrooms right and you know
one kitchen yeah and then a whole bunch
of highly efficient space you know
apartments get more complicated to build
and you know there's way more plumbing
stacks and HVAC issues and all these
kind of things so for an execution
perspective they're very different but
but again the foundational why behind
them it is can be so similar so if you
were to design a Wii City let's say you
could start from scratch like what is it
you know what does that look like you
know it's a great question because I
mean I've we were talking about that
this today because I drove to work for
the first time in my life today we were
in LA and you know everyone drives so we
were like we rented a Tesla which I
hadn't driven and Tesla before been in
when they hadn't driven him like I mean
the gas pedal like it's like a roller
coaster a little bit which is cool yeah
um but but I drove to work
like went into the parking garage and I
suck at all that like I didn't know I
just I didn't remembered where I parked
like I didn't pay attention anyway I'm
just bad at like all stuff really the
cars I'm really terrible but um but
point is is that I've always been you
know walking biking sub weighing now and
I really love that and so I think that
there's like the first thing I think
transit and transportation is just a
huge part of in the city and when that
you know so the first time I heard about
autonomous cars and even uber as a idea
that no one would ever Park and then
someone said think of a city where no
one ever parks that was one of the
coolest things I heard about the future
of cities because obviously it's cool to
think of other ways of transit but even
just the fact that our streets could be
liberated from all these cars and what
could you use the space for and I mean
la you just imagine like if you made I
mean just the scooter lane yeah could be
amazing here and take half the people
out of their cars and put them on those
cool scooters I mean and make it safe
for I'm so anyway that's not as
visionary as we wouldn't need to get to
and and I haven't haven't indulged in it
enough but I do think that what what I
think would would one of the things that
would be fundamentally different is that
we would just be much less governed by
the typical systems of time in the way
that we usually work now which is like
you wake up in the morning do your
routine get to work spend whatever
number of hours that is you know eight
or ten hours a day you go to at home you
have dinner you work out you go to bed
right like I think that there's for me
at least being much more free-flowing
about that you know we're really
untethered we can be really untethered
ideas can come in efficient working
could come in all kinds of different
times places and spaces so if you can
imagine just a network of like you it
you said you know when you're working at
home I'm sure you have the times where
it's
like one space really works for you but
and it's great and you're engaged and
it's there's other people around and
there's a buzz and then other times you
got to get completely out you got to be
in your own private box you know and so
if you can imagine a city working that
way where it's much it's less more about
binary you know I'm in or I'm out but
much more about a spectrum and you're
always existing in some kind of
different spectrum of entertainment work
health life you know we talked about
walking meetings yeah trying to promote
that so it's like just this much more
spectrum oriented threshold free
environment that just feels like I'm
alive all the time I'm doing good stuff
all the time I'm in a good mental
mindset all the time not like switch
into this switch into that switch you
know what I mean because I think that's
I don't know i think that we show up i
mean my feeling is that we we we would
we could show up differently if we were
like that like if we were just much more
free rather than compartmentalized well
there's no question about that i mean
you know our cities our urban landscapes
were designed in a different time with
different priorities and a lot of them
without much mindfulness whatsoever
I mean Los Angeles perfect example of
that like it just went up and now it's
here and we're dealing with you know so
many problems that are that could have
been resolved at the inception
had it been you know had it been well
thought out and planned from the outset
yeah and and you know with what we know
now if like you could just wipe it out
and start over you know imagine how much
better it could be what's weird about LA
coming from New York is that like the
assets of LA are like so amazing you
know like it's like New York is not like
you're gonna go find this incredible
Canyon or like a beautiful orange tree
that you know or like a garden or you
know what I mean it's like it's you're
finding urban everywhere but it takes
you two hours to go 15 miles right
exactly so you may or never you know not
even get to those things like you may
close your mind
to the idea that you're even going to
experience that diversity but if you can
imagine like incredible high speed
you know transit here and super
convenient public transportation and it
would be like oh yeah I'm gonna be on
the mountain or at the beach or you know
wherever that might be in like and it
doesn't and it feels frictionless then
this would be like the Wonderland you
know we'll get on that small problem
all right well green desk was conceived
with this environmental sensibility and
now you're kind of starting to explore
that with we work you announced this
meatless initiative that made a lot of
news all around the world which I
thought was amazing I would imagine that
was a risky maneuver for you guys
it's a bold statement and super cool so
can you kind of talk about what went
into making that decision yeah it's
interesting because the motivation on
some level was not about not necessarily
about me itself but about accountability
and about you know personal choices and
the impact that we have and and these
things have come up over time not about
me but about like paper you know or
energy like our lights you know being on
and why I don't know you know an atom to
his credit is very aware all the time of
like inefficiency like he sees things
and he's like I walked down the street
and the lights are on at a we work
building why are they on you know this
has got to be a waste of energy and and
he's paying attention these things all
the time and then we're looking for like
okay what switches in your mind where
you start to care about these things
rather than just like walking past them
without thinking about it and so we had
I mean Adams fearless leader doesn't
have any like worry about saying or
doing things that you know would be
controversial and so we were discussing
like what are the things that we could
do that would increase you know personal
accountability and that one came up and
it
wasn't actually you know a big we didn't
think of it as a huge decision I mean I
think he knew in saying it for the first
time that it would actually people would
be like whoa um I actually didn't I was
just like oh yeah that's like I was like
whoa I can't believe that he actually
said it cuz he said it when it was still
you know
TBD of to Weatherly it wasn't like a
fully baked idea it wasn't like we
prepared the whole comms team like you
know prepared a whole thing and that's
the way we've done a lot of stuff over
time is just instinct and intuition and
just like right time just do something
you know but it was part of an overall
discussion in about that personal
accountability and so I took that as
like this is amazing because it actually
is a spike that pretty much nothing else
would get you know like you can ask
people to like be more aware of their
choices in a lot of other areas of life
and it's kind of an you know like we've
we also have eliminated plastic from our
operations right and like you know it's
easy to forget and you still go out to
the local deli or whatever and come back
with a bag full of you know plastic
flatware or whatever in but meat has
been you don't forget that one you know
it comes up in your brain it's like if
you're going out to dinner you know
you're gonna remember that that was
something and then you have to ask
yourself what do you do with that
information and I think what we've seen
I'm sure some people could care less
they've gone and lived their life
normally but we've also seen a lot of
people are like this is the first time
I've ever thought about that before this
is the first time I've ever understood
the implications of my choices when it
comes to food
that's the stuff I get super excited
about is that we've also heard people
say hey I've talked to my family about
it it's influenced the way that we as a
family I have a really good friend who
sends me pictures all the time of their
family eating you know vegetarian
and-and-and and it sounds like kind of
crazy but like their kids who are you
know 19 20 and whatever who are like
really proud vegetarians and vegans
because of our influence they're not
even lirik members they just happen to
be friends but they're just they
connected to it so that's the stuff that
I think actually
we'll have a ripple effect uh-huh you
know have you seen that ripple effects
in other corporate cultures well like
you kind of broke a seal on that it
comes up it's come up in different
contexts so one of the examples is that
you know I you know in talking to
leaders in both HR other business fields
we're we get I get the feeling that
we're creating space for other for
conversations right so if if people look
at us as like the crazy ones who are
doing the wild stuff and we're also
thought of as like a cool company that
people know about and they can say hey
look we're in we want to hire the same
talent that we work is gonna get look at
what people who work there care about
like their mission-driven their
purpose-driven we need to find that -
right what are the signals that we can
find within ourselves that are gonna put
us in a place where we can even be on
the close to the same page as them right
so I haven't seen anyone else go so far
as but you know I've been in a lot of
conversations where people have said hey
we're thinking about something like that
we're thinking about doing something and
I'm very like I mean I've gotten you
know a lot of knowledge in conversations
with people - in understanding how like
misaligned companies are in terms of the
efforts that they make so you know you
can have a company like a big bank who
has said we have a new 200 million
dollar fund to invest in you know green
technology and we believe wholeheartedly
that you know we have to support
innovation in this area or else we're
all screwed right so they can say that
yeah and then I'll be like so have you
got are you still eating meat in your
cafeteria yeah they're like what do you
what what you know what what are you
talking about I'm not working the dots
on it this all comes all Tice care and
then also say you know what what do you
do with you know what what is your CSR
program your impact program look like in
there like oh oh wait a minute like it
doesn't all come together and I think
that's the kind of thing
we're excited about being in those
conversations I just be able to initiate
that conversation and get people
thinking about it a little bit
differently and and start being mindful
of like working towards some you know
form of carbon neutrality or working
towards you know reducing that carbon
footprint yeah and I would say one thing
that I've one of the effective
techniques and I promote it for other
people who are
convenors or people who gather smart
people one of the things that I've been
saying is that whenever you're bringing
people together where food is not the
point meaning you're not going to a
place to eat the best flank steak or
whatever it is or you know or you're
bringing together thought leaders who
should be able to at least understand
that there's something bigger going on
here then make those events meat-free
make those the time when you don't serve
meat because it's not like you know
people are really protective of like
grandma's meatballs or whatever you know
they're like we're not gonna give that
up like our family needs that but like
the like chicken breast and steak at
like a crappy catered event that's not
even really the meal yeah like who cares
it's like that's pointless that's
nothing to do with while you're there
right so most people have received that
I've gotten a few immediate reactions of
like [ __ ] off what are you talking about
and then you're trying to police my life
exactly but you're not you're just
saying we're not gonna pay for it well
in our case yeah we're not gonna pay for
it we're not gonna be a part of you know
the consumption but I think there's the
other level of you know if you're
appealing to people who are smart people
who care they might not be ready to make
that leap themself but I think that you
can at least say I mean we know like
reduce the terian is the thing right
like it would make a huge difference if
we just had less consumption so look for
those opportunities to consume less yeah
and then that will collectively if that
spreads we change the expectations of
like you know what we need from those
kind of events and then those are all
business leaders who care okay now their
mind is open why don't we have meat
here's why oh wow
okay have you I mean because you're
doing this on such a huge scale have you
run the numbers on this is the amount of
water that we're gonna save this is the
carbon emissions that were sparing yeah
those animals I mean there's got to be
stats on them we've done some of that
I'm like so not the numbers person
um Adam has definitely commissioned
those reports I mean the numbers are big
Coffee is a huge one which we're trying
to figure out because you know
implications of coffee are big and we
serve a lot um you know we're doing a
lot of study of our supply chain to try
to understand where things come from and
our you know we have a team that's a
sustainability team that I am already
super impressed with trying to create
you know not only understand where
things come from but where do they go
after they come into our buildings and
we're looking at ways that we can always
keep them inside so you know and this is
a long-term thing but saying when
something comes into a wework building
it never leaves whatever that might be I
don't we don't know for sure what that
means yet but that's what we're looking
at is that circular you know path and
then also really really understanding we
have wood deaths we have wood flooring
and fill materials come from all the
building materials so and the cool thing
about our scale is that we can actually
be you know market movers in that way
right so it's like our buying decisions
could have influence and that's
something I'm trying to learn more about
I've heard some great stories from
people who have been empowered by that
who have they've known that they have
see a huge power requirement for a
factory or whatever and they're able to
influence you know government in a
country to say all build the wind farm
you update the grid to deliver me my
renewable power for example and that's
the kind of stuff I'm getting excited
it's very early stage for us but that's
the kind of stuff I get excited about
I'm saying like at scale we could now
influence you know a role in this
country or this city that we haven't
been in before but here's what's gonna
have to happen exactly that's like real
power yeah and think of it I mean
there's so many downstream implications
of that that can be so positive if if
you you know look at the ways that um
you know cities
care about economic development they are
motivated by jobs they're motivated by
you know things that so so if we say
we're gonna build something locally
whether that's a sofa or a chair or a
desk or light fixtures or whatever you
know you're talking about a pretty good
good amount of economic potential there
right so that can actually move the
needle you guys have announced that
you're you have this goal of being
carbon neutral but I like I don't know
twenty thirty or something like that
right yeah twenty twenty three twenty
twenty three yeah which is um actually
you know it's not that hard in the
places where renewable power is
available it's very difficult in the
places where it you know where the grid
is not you know if you don't have a grid
that gets the power into the city and
where in the city you know we're gonna
be facing challenges there but those are
challenges were again we're just super
excited about engaging it I don't have
all those answers but but um but I think
like a year from now we're gonna have a
really awesome story to tell about that
and how we're figuring it out and then
also add we believe we can be a convener
of other companies so if we're talking
about scale it's like you know other
companies that want to be Purpose Driven
mission driven care about the future
believe in their role in helping with
climate change if we're the convener of
those companies and now we say hey look
we've got out of all the office
buildings in downtown we could get 20%
of them now that's even you know more
buying power right that could move you
know things to happen right so that's
the stuff that we get excited about and
that could apply in you know different
places like we said from transportation
we're looking at things in LA of like
what we could do point-to-point between
buildings to reduce driving things like
that so a lot of future there which
should be fun how important do you think
it is in in 2019 for for you know young
entrepreneurs people that are starting
businesses to think in terms of you know
triple bottom-line values well you know
it's weird cuz I exist in that world so
I thought everyone was that way already
but I I had a conversation yesterday
with the woman Julie
who I'm coming to know and really
appreciating she's a early technologist
and entrepreneur in the Bay Area who's
an investor in a lot of different
companies and you know she was seeing it
differently she's like you know maybe
for lucky it's 5050 um in terms of like
mercenary versus missionary what's the
advice that you give to young people
looking to start businesses like what do
you I mean he blazed this extraordinary
entrepreneurial path you know what have
you learned from that well I I used to
say this differently but I was talking
to a I had a event with Sean King a
couple weeks ago and he had this cool
framing where he said you have to I hope
I'll say it the right way he said you
need to find out find what you love to
do and then you need to find what you
really care about and if those two
things match up meaning if you can use
what you love to do to address what you
really care about then you will have
found your thing mmm and I think that's
for me I hadn't heard it in that way
exactly before but if you look at it for
me it's like I feel like I really cared
about human centered design I really
cared about I really loved design I
loved the process of like rigorous
problem-solving like that was my I would
do it without getting paid right look
there's always like the thing what would
you do if you find the thing you would
do without being paid and then you apply
that to a business problem which is that
workspace suck people are disconnected
you know everyone's lonely that was a
you know perfect connection point for me
so that's what I would encourage people
to do is look for really to understand
like where does their core the depth of
their being where does where did what
are they what do they love to do what
would they do if they're not getting
paid and then how does that apply to an
actual business problem a social problem
something that they feel really
passionate about being a part of
changing and that I think once you find
that then it's like it doesn't really
matter the scale of the business or the
level of success or you know like you
become a millionaire all that other [ __ ]
doesn't really
matter anymore because now you're just
existing in this place where you're
doing something that feels like a full
expression of yourself yeah if you can
match that with a problem that really
needs to get solved right where where
there's a service component to it and a
need yeah and that's a try that's why I
would say like don't start another photo
sharing app you know I mean like no one
needs that hmm what do we need you know
I mean let's start over
well I mean that you know that there
there's there's a lot of slices and we I
think we're again like the world that I
live in I think that we see a lot of
people finding that slice and and it
comes in weird forms I mean our creator
Awards which we give out to companies
that are in efforts I mean you know
nonprofit for-profit we say creators
because they're not necessarily
entrepreneurs in the similar sense it
could be artists whatever it could be
but in krater words the winner of this
last year was the company that does
something that seems really kind of
weird but they they're basically like a
marketplace for used medical equipment
and that sounds not so awesome that it's
you know without understanding it too
well but the way I understand it is that
you know they're through taking
underutilized medical equipment from
hospitals that have already like
upgraded to their new MRI machine or
whatever now they've got this old one
just collecting dust in the corner if
you can actually make that one available
to a hospital that can buy it at a
discounted rate that doesn't have an MRI
machine at all in some you know smaller
town that you know used to be like you
have to drive two hours like you've
actually done something to support a
small community and their health for
example right and those are the kind of
things where it's like well you know
that's a really narrow slice of the
business world but it's actually doing
something impactful and I think that's
what what we get excited about is that
there's so many if you're thinking about
it in the right way and your motivation
is really to do good there's a lot of
opportunity you know there's a lot of
places to find something that's not what
gets the Lakehead line of like the
hottest new startup you know
you seem like a super grounded dude how
do you yeah is like looking around are
you is he not like you're pretty chill
dude
for like you know you could be you know
rockin and a different kind of lifestyle
you know I mean you don't seem like
you're you seem like you have a very
healthy relationship with your ego I can
hear the humility in your voice and you
you truly you know come across as
mission driven and value-based in your
approach your life and your business so
you know how to what do you attribute
that or like how do you like maintain
that sense of self that's something I
mean I've been trying to figure out in
different times because it's it's hard
to understand but like like I've had
some of the weirdest questions in that
way like there was this one guy who
literally walked up to me one day and he
was like one of our employees and he
goes hey man I just really wanted to ask
you this like how are you you and I'm
like like yeah and I'm like what can you
expand on that he's like he's just like
you know it just doesn't make sense like
you're like you know you're like so
successful you know like it's just not
what people expect but I don't know
exactly what I don't have a counterpoint
in my own brain of what I could be right
like I'm just myself so it's hard to
like I don't envy I can't perceive a
different me right other people yeah I
mean they're people can be like
surprised or disarmed or like well this
guy's different than I expected but I
don't have that so all I can you know
the thing that I get to is that what I
feel really good about is that and I and
I'm trying to I am trying to understand
why but I just feel like really
comfortable being myself all the time
you know I feel like I'm my authentic
self no matter whether I'm talking to
you and it's recorded and there's
cameras or whether I'm speaking in front
of you know doing a commencement address
in front of my you know at my university
or whether it's speaking to someone who
literally just like
me at the airport and it's like hey are
you Miguel and I'm like yeah I mean I
think I wasn't expecting anyone to know
who I was but I am and have a having an
authentic connection with that person
not just being like put off by that and
I think um I don't know why that is I
just feel really good about it like I
feel like really and I and I believe
that once I felt it I've indulged in it
like I've been like you know I'm not
gonna ever believe that I have to put on
some other faiths yeah I just won't do
it well it's nice and it's refreshing
you know in in a in a kind of period of
time that we're in right now where you
know the Elizabeth Holmes story is you
know top of mind with the documentary I
just watched it and I wanted to the like
six-part podcast series too which is
like amazing it's fantastic I'm like
obsessed and the fire fest of all
documentaries and all this where you see
these you know these quote-unquote you
know entrepreneurs that have you know
their ego spiral out of control and and
there is no connection with authenticity
and they're not grounded and you know
perhaps you know these are journeys that
began with good intentions but you know
trajectories that spiraled out of
control
yeah I mean I have to attribute a big
part of that to being partners with Adam
and him giving me the freedom to be
myself because I didn't always have to
show up in front of everyone you know so
he was the face when we're talking to
early investors you know he still has
the high level relationships with people
where it really you know that funding
and financing that you referenced which
is to an extraordinary amount you know
and you judge it from the outside you
know he's the one who's had to show up
in some of these very from the very
beginning and high-intensity exchanges
situations and I've been able to do my
thing you know I was able to build up a
credibility by being a part of that
creative process of building the
experience and the in the business and
the brand and stuff like that in a way
that just was very natural to me I
didn't and then hatch something else
from that you know and and and so you
know again that goes back to that
partnership of like what were we able to
do and what was some of the magic of it
it it allowed me to be me though the
whole way through and I'm still I still
feel like I'm finding out who I am I'm
on the journey and I hope to continue to
evolve it's not like I'm like I made it
so I still see it as like okay we're
figuring it out like I have complex [ __ ]
to deal with in my own head and I'm
working on it yeah you know how do you
instill these ideas in the in the
management team like how is that how
does that go downstream to make sure
that that integrity remains intact well
for me I mean that's a lot of just
leadership by example meaning I just try
to show up in every context that I can
as my authentic self and I promote that
I will say it's not like a really
proactive like like leader circle as an
example which I did this morning with
the local leadership team here in LA
that's an exercise which we did just to
find vulnerability and share stories and
be ourselves hopefully our authentic
selves for two hours out of our lives
are busy week our day whatever but I
think that that kind of connection is
one means something to yourself then it
means something to those around you and
then there's something that just going
through that exercise of connecting to
yourself will flow to the people who as
leaders now said their teams right I
don't know if they'll conduct the
leadership circle I hope they do it
would be cool if they did but just the
fact that they got in touch with
themself I think will help them show up
differently and so that's a lot of what
I try to do is conduct those kind of
experiences where they where you get
into something that perhaps you aren't
normally asked for in your regular
business life
and and and that's something which again
I think it's like practicing what I
preach to some extent of actually making
time for those kind of experiences and
we do it you know if I go to Seoul we do
it with a group of leaders there when we
you know go to another city it's like
that's the exercise that we do as well
as other things but make time for that
and you know Adam is oh and I also you
know at all company meetings I will try
to connect people to context and give us
perspective about where we are and and
how he should how we show up but Adam
also plays a role of being you know a
visionary leader from a much more
specific side you know meaning like here
are business goals talk about our growth
you know talking about how we as
individuals have to perform in order to
reach these big goals that were setting
for ourselves and what does it take you
know as a person to show up in this yeah
equation so it's still a play you know
it's still a play and I don't I don't
have a lot of like specific
accountability for that stuff it's not
like I'm running a Leadership Program
it's like I'm just trying to embody it
and that's why it's so cool to be in
both of those places at the same time
it's like we do something really hard we
make spaces for people to exist in
people are a pain in the ass right they
don't they don't do what you want them
to do air conditioning one person's hot
one person cold sitting this close to
each other right maximize that to half a
million people around the world
you're the biggest human resources you
know it's Department in the world
exactly and they're not your employees
right if all the people work for you
it's like you just go hey just take it
you know you're like you're you know
it's like but these are people who are
paying us their monthly membership fees
so they're like if I'm paying the fee I
want the temperature that makes me
comfortable which is totally fair
assumption all right it's hard sometimes
to negotiate with a person like that
who's like yeah but but the person next
to you so anyway so that's hard every
day delivering hot coffee making the
bathrooms work you know cleaning the
bathroom having a smile
on your face every day as a community
manager when the member walks in you
know that these are things that are in a
very difficult business to execute again
at scale with great speed but then like
what are you a part of that makes all of
that worthwhile it has to be something
way bigger you got to feel like if
you're like on the front lines in like
Jakarta and you are opening a building
and all you've got is your local team
and you're like we got to open on the
1st of the month no matter what because
members are moving in I mean that is a
stressful situation for them and they're
far away from you know they don't get to
see what's going on at our HQ in New
York and feel that energy they're a
small team that's so far and yet they
feel like they're doing something that
matters they feel like they're actually
moving the world forward when they open
those doors and the members come in they
believe they're doing something good and
that's like so that that to me is a big
part of my responsibility is to keep
helping them connect to that energy you
know all right well we got to wrap this
up in a minute here but I can't let you
go without asking you how you maintain
balance in your own life as somebody
who's whose job is to create workplaces
and foster a healthier relationship with
work like does it feel weird when that
gets out of whack in your own life like
how do you show up and be you know a
loving and present partner and father
while trying to like steward this like
massive organization well I will say
that for a long time I didn't do that
well I think that I was unhealthy and
the way I approached my life outside of
work I do think that for my son's life
I've really dedicated the right energy
to him but in other places I think that
I wasn't good at it
but I went through divorce and I was re
establishing myself and who I am and I
met someone and fell in love with her
and she is amazing and she shifted my
appreciation for a whole other part of
life that I just to be honest that
completely ignored and that was the
enjoyment of like dinner or you know
actually enjoying it not just eating it
functionally but like going out and
enjoying it and like actually having
some appreciation for like and I still
have to work on this so you know that of
like how was your day you know present
being present and in care but caring
about that like I can again I can preach
that at work but then it's like at home
and just be like oh you know this is I
don't know something else I think I
thought about it before is like you know
recovery time almost as an athlete it's
like this is the time to just like you
know functionally repair but not
actually be present and you know that it
has equal value in a way and so that's
been a huge shift for me and I know even
Jillian my assistant who I work with she
knows and she's very good at helping me
being much more aware of like making a
schedule that that helps me achieve more
of this I don't necessarily call it
balance but I would just say cuz I do
think it's like a spectrum it doesn't
mean I'm not thinking about work at the
time when I'm doing other things but it
is like just a greater level of
awareness and and then so with Jesse and
I when we're together I think that we
try to be present with each other and
not so and that's a commitment which
again I feel I take seriously and I and
I love it like I got a lot of good yeah
it is a practice it is and when there's
a lot of other inputs that could easily
take over that whether they're in
work or they're just life or they're
like I mean to be honest we discuss like
do we listen to too many podcasts
sometime cuz you know it's like you feel
like you need to learn and you need to
grow and you have to like the the latest
amazing person is on rich roll you got
to listen to it
but it's two hours yeah we've got two
and a half today so you know you have to
ask yourself like I encourage people
listen to it but at the same time it's
like okay at what point do you stop that
consumption and actually be a you know
president yet obviously there's commute
and other times you can do that but it's
like but yeah I think that that's like
you said it's like it's a practice and
something to be as purposeful in that in
life as you are at work and I think that
will always you know that's always an
opportunity to do better try to find
that you know purpose and and to and to
be good at it like to try to be really
good at it yeah good man it's good
talking to you yeah I really have
enjoyed this I always say like I learn
from these experiences because I learned
from speaking which sounds really maybe
self-absorbed but I feel like I learned
a lot too well the more that you the
more the ear that's Larry's yeah the
more that you share your own story the
more it tells you what it is and what's
important right or you try to figure out
like what is it about that experience
that could be helpful or meaningful in
my own and how I think about myself and
how I communicate right I know that's
been the experience in my case well all
I can tell you is look I know what it's
like to suffer in an insufferable work
environment and to be in an in an
uninspiring you know architectural
professional habitat and I appreciate
what you're doing man and you really
have impacted the world in a way that
few people on earth can say and it's
inspiring what you've built and I can
you know I can feel the intention behind
it and it's a beautiful thing man so
wind in your sails my friend thank you
yeah what's next you know we're actually
trying to get into
I knew Sunday Sermons how nice so are we
that's me back out in Calabasas try to
convince them that were worthy of
attendance what's the angle
dude if you can't get in you know come
on you sure you got it you I'm sure you
could find a way to finagle that so well
yeah we're meeting with someone who
works with Kanye so yeah if you likes us
enough maybe he'll give us awesome now
yeah all right cool
Miguel I appreciate you thanks man if
people want to learn more about your
world just go to we work right the best
any any other place you you're on
Twitter your name I don't use Twitter
about really use it Instagram a little
but huh I don't know that's a really
good question I should have a good
answer to it but I have no idea how
you're supposed to learn more about I
would Google I guess if people could
Google you right yeah I think you should
go on YouTube I think my I like your
your speech your you're my commencement
yes that's way too few views so I think
that people should watch that that's
agree I watched a promotion it is very
authentic I appreciated like the honesty
and just the kind of like unabashedly
unpretentious way in which you showed up
for that it's very cool thank you yeah
no all right you come back to talk to me
again sometime
[Music]